bonjour bonjour et bienvenue sur la
chaîne youtube
elle est loin l'époque où tout le monde
sait ce quiz here aujourd'hui on va se
faire péter le cerveau bla bla nous
sommes sûrs ecoflex est complexe qu'est
ce que c'est un mot qui rime avec duplex
corn flakes voilà plus de rythme c'est
trop compliqué pour moi c'est un joueur
lequel il va y avoir un écho de
nous-mêmes qui va reproduire ce qu'on
fait mais avec quelques secondes d'écart
ou suivait jusqu'à la cie cet écho nous
choque
nous mourrons et nous perdons la partie
le but va donc être de passer les sacs
niveau de la halle fera pour gagner et
pour se dire qu'on a été intelligent et
se sentir bien à l'essai par type l'aï
démo j'ai découvert ça avec vous je sens
qu'on va perdre dix mille fois donc ça
je suppose c'est la porte d'où les co va
sortir à temps je vais harper que le
voir steco de merde donc il a décoché
sur audacity jeu mais l'effet réduire
les qu il ya plus d'écho un excellent
avait en fait me lebel va être grand
d'accord je sais pas à partir de quand
eu l'écho va arriver mais je pense qu'il
va arriver hp dans cette caste ou john
d'accord oulala locked et le stranger
d'accord donc le prix nobel n'avait pas
d'écho parfait se réduit également le
premier niveau d'un autre jeu qui
s'appelle pas et kobe du progrès c'est
parti on passe dans la porte et lost
renders level 2 bon ok c'est bon il est
là donc maintenant il répète ce qu'on
fait à voyez là il y reste à ce jour là
comme nous tout à l'heure le problème
c'est qu'en patience et de parts à
déverrouiller ça et que lui quand il va
passer à la ronde des mères ou bien
c'est bon pour y aller ok si vous avez
suivi c'est important explications en
images
j'ai attendu dans le froid pendant 8
secondes lorsque l'école est arrivé j'ai
traversé une sorte de portail qui a
verrouillé la porte qui se situer
derrière il fallait donc que j'attende
que mon écot travers ce portail à son
taux pour ouvrir la porte que moi
j'avais verrouillé moi même c'est
compris 18h21 alice 2 sur 20 alors
tailleur trappe
level 3 ok donc là on passe là ok les
coûts vient d'arriver quand il ya ce
petit truc alors attends là il ya une
porte qui verrouille et je pense qu'il
faut
passer là dedans hop ça des verrous
n'importe quel à attends je sais pas ce
que ça fait ça à derrick hall date à
annoncer moi qui ai attendus tout à
l'heure
oh [ __ ] j'ai plus envie ce chien mais
je peux passer des coûts ouais c'est bon
je peux passer
et là je passe la up hees a verrouillé
la porte qu'elle a et donc faut que
j'attende qu'il arrive pour pouvoir
passer c'est juste ça ah mais non c'est
bon jeu avec l'air de ne pas de génie de
boulot c'est quand tu crois avoir
d'écoles d'ingénieurs que pas du tout
tahi les lots 1 alors là c'est
impossible j'ai dû fermer une porte la
spa beauce il ya un truc que j'ai dû
verrouiller il devrait déjà y est arrivé
il est où qu'est-ce qui fait oui tourner
en haut à g vu rouillé la porte qui la
merde faut que la débrouille ça en
passant la dengue est déverrouillé assez
bon regardez j'ai ouverte
ok maintenant les paupières faut tracer
ma survie ou pas ou géré verrouiller un
truc mais non non mais c'est un sketch
wahaha
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon je suis
passé je suis passé aucun est bon vous
avez compris ou pas explications en
images
mon épouse va me suivre je suis donc
passé par une porte nommé la porte a
derrière laquelle se situe le portail à
en patientera le portail à la porte
assez fermé ce qui fait que monde et
qu'on n'a pas pu me suivre
j'ai dû revenir en arrière pour que
cette porte s'ouvre et que mon écot
puisse me suivre voilà je sais que c'est
au pct explications elles servent que
vous avez déjà tout compris mais elles
vous plaisent alors lost time ya déjà
deux portails d'entrée de jeu à temps
mais comment mon clown waouh
j'ai paniqué et j'ai paniqué je suis
grosse pas quand je passe la nao qu'elle
apportait pas verrouillé c'est juste un
truc absolue je vais passer faut que
j'attende que mon clown passe de l'autre
côté de la pièce pour que ça s'ouvre ok
ça s'est ouvert c'est qu'il est passé je
trace watts
je me suis enfermé je pense qu'il faut
pas du peintre d'avant sans faute c'est
bon c'est bon au maire je suis enfermée
avec lui non j'ai pas compris la caisse
qui ouvre quoi à temps ok ah merde
ok j'ai compris à yann hostiou oil et
oil et âgées patent dès juillet res 4,4
[ __ ] ça met la pression en gros quand
il passe ici ça ouvre la porte kate le
côté mais quand il passe ici ça à la
ferme
donc le mieux c'est que je temporise
entre les deux que j'ai le temps de
passer voilà c'est bon elana manche ce
week-end
vous avez compris ou pas les
explications en direct live est
anormalement l'éducation nationale me
donne mon diplôme de professeur quoi je
suis désolé mais là alors ici qu'est ce
qui se passe on a un portail d'entrée de
jeu obtient deux portails à quoi ça peut
servir à je pense qu'il faut qu'ils
viennent
ok faut qu'ils passent à traire comme ça
ça leur ouvre non ok ça lover mais
comment jouve ça je suis bébé la merde
alors attendez ce level c'etait un
c'est un calvaire en gros là on a un
premier portail je ne sais pas quoi il
sert mais je pense qu'il devrait une
porte bleue ok la porte bleue qui est là
bas
voilà vu qu'il vient de passer à travers
ce bref d'épaisses à la ferme est donc
ce qu'on va faire c'est très simple
c'est qu'on va temporiser ici on va
attendre le plus con peu puis on va
temporiser ici on va attendre le plus
qu'on peut puis on va y aller c'est la
merde non je pense juste qu'il faut
temporiser ici et maintenant y aller
voilà comme ça il passera pas à travers
et moi j'aurai le temps de passer j'ai
une théorie l'asie passe si je vais la
haac et c'est bon je trouvais justement
je trouve et je trouve trouvait en fait
faut le faire courir
là je vais attendre ici et normalement
je devrais peut-être avoir le temps de
passer au camp ça fout les boules lutte
aux questions récapitule le portail bleu
ici présent que je viens de passer
permet d'ouvrir la porte qu'il a juste
là à droite la porte bleue le problème
c'est que j'ai fait en attente parce
qu'elle se ferme avant lui porta jaune
ici permet de bloquer mon double est
quand je bloque qu'est-ce qui fait les
repasse la barre toi mais c'est juste à
temps ça s'trouve fallait que je le bloc
comme ça il fait demi tour et j'ai le
temps d'y aller c'est frustrant
logiquement il va retourner vers le bleu
là j'ai pas tout compris ce que j'ai
fait mais je crois qu'il va retourner
derrière le bloc on va pouvoir passer
normal c'est à s'ouvrir time's up oh non
non je vous jure ça laisse à bombay
toujours fait tout en deux parties
ok voilà cette fois on a huit minutes 11
pour y arriver autant visuel c'est à le
faire donc à mon avis là je viens
d'ouvrir la porte qui avait là bas ok
quand je vais là hop ça verrouille cette
porte là et je suis persuadé qu'il ya un
truc à faire pour que ce qu'on soit
bloquée et que je gagne du temps sur la
loupe
à mon avis c'est ça attaque au vert
c'est compliqué [ __ ] si là il est en
train de me casser en gros la lâcheté
entend le faire briller c'est à dire
qu'il veut faire mouvement que j'ai fait
mais ils perdent tout à la fois ça y est
la bei est ça y est la bague et je crois
qu'il est en train de faire une loupe
infinie parce qu on y est y as c'est ça
vous êtes échappée de les complexes
c'est management sava compris en fait
donc les côtoie m reproduit les
mouvements tu fais avec quatre secondes
de décalage sauf que des fois ils vivent
heures pour dire ce que tu veux mais ya
une porte qui va le bloquer et quand il
ya une porte qui le bloque il reprend la
loupe à partir de cinq secondes avant et
c'est ce qui s'est passé dans 1 et
niveau quand je suis parti dans la salle
où il ya la porte pour s'échapper du
niveau il a voulu me suivre mais la
porte jaune s'est fermé devant lui et
l'a donc compris la loupe à partir de
cinq secondes avant et 5 secondes avant
il était de l'autre côté du portail bleu
sniffer qui m'a ouvert la porte de la
sortie que j'ai pu m'en allais le fait
est que j'ai pas trop compris comment la
porte jaune à puce fermé merde à
s'adapter cerveau
en tout cas c'est un [ __ ] de jeu face
à vous a plu ne sait pas aimer les deux
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas aussi à
soutenir ce jeu sur steam greenlight
parce qu'il faut absolument qu'ils
s'attardent sur steam c'est trop ouf la
moitié des trucs comme ça que j'arrive à
résoudre j'y arrive et je sais pas
comment j'ai fait c'est horrible
qu'avant c'est ce qu'on appelle la
chance et l'incompétence à la tenue
prochaine vidéo mère de me regarder
j'espère ce petit jaune à une femme vous
aura plu